[Music]
now when they sailed from Greenland
during the summer he and his men were
driven out of their course to the Sutra
jar they were slow in getting favourable
wind from this place and they stayed
there a long time during the summer
reaching no way about harvest tide
[Music]
he joined the bodyguard of King Olaf
Tryggvason
and the King formed an excellent opinion
of him and it appeared to him that Leif
was a well-bred man once upon a time the
King entered into conversation with Leif
and asked him does thou purpose sailing
to Greenland in summer Leif answered I
should wish to do so if it is your will
the king replied I think it may well be
so thou shalt go my errand and preach
Christianity in Greenland Leif said that
he was willing to undertake it but that
for himself he considered that message a
difficult one to proclaim in Greenland
but the king said that he knew no man
who was better fitted for the work than
he and thou shalt Kerry said he good
luck with the innit that can only be
said Leif if I carry yours with me
leave set sail as soon as he was ready
he was tossed about a long time out at
sea and lighted upon lands of which
before he had no expectation there were
fields of wild wheat and the vine tree
in full growth there were also the trees
which were called maples and they
gathered of all these certain tokens
some trunks so large that they were used
in house building Leif came upon men who
had been shipwrecked and took them home
with him and gave them sustenance during
the winter thus did he show his great
munificence and his graciousness when he
brought Christianity to the land and
saved the shipwrecked crew he was called
Leif the lucky the people received him
gladly he soon after preached
Christianity and Catholic truth
throughout the land making known to the
people the message of King Olaf
Tryggvason and declaring how many
renowned deeds and what great glory
accompanied this faith
Eric took coldly to the proposal to
forsake his religion but his wife
thought dilled promptly yielded and
caused the church to be built not very
near the house in that spot she offered
her prayers and so did those men who
received Christ and they were many after
she accepted the faith stilled would
have no intercourse with Eric and this
was a great trial to his temper
[Music]
after this there was much talk about
making ready to go to the land which
leaf had discovered thorstein eirik's
son was chief mover in this a worthy man
wise and much liked Eric was also asked
to go and they believed that his luck
and foresight would be of the highest
use he was for a long time against it
but did not say nay when his friends
exhorted him to go they made ready the
ship which thorbjørn had brought there
and there were 20 men who undertook to
start in her they had little property
but chiefly weapons and food on the
morning when Eric left home he took a
little box which had in it gold and
silver he hid the money and then went
forth on his journey he had proceeded
however but a little way when he fell
from his horse and broke his ribs and
injured his shoulder and cried out ie at
this accident he sent word to his wife
that she should take away the money that
he had hidden declaring his misfortune
to be a penalty paid on account of
having hid the money afterwards they
sailed away out of Eric's filled with
gladness as that plan seemed to promise
success they were driven about for a
long time on the open sea and came not
into the track which they desired they
came in sight of Iceland and also met
with birds from the coast of Ireland
then was their ship tossed to and fro on
the sea they returned about harvest tide
worn out by toil and much exhausted and
reached Eric's fuel at the beginning of
winter
[Music]
you